there is a reason that we and other news
organizations have generally stopped
giving an unfiltered live platform to
remarks by former president Trump there
is a cost to us as a news organization
of knowingly broadcasting untrue things
that was msnbc's Rachel mattow
explaining why her network refused to
air Donald Trump's victory speech after
he won the Iowa caucus her reasoning is
dead wrong now it's true Trump does say
some crazy and untrue things but so do
all political figures so does mattow
herself anybody remember when she spent
years promoting the Russia gate
conspiracy theories the point is
shielding viewers from Trump's speech is
a tactic that has utterly failed it's
not making Trump less popular in fact
Trump's favorability is rising people
may have forgotten what they disliked
about Trump in part because the media is
too afraid to actually air his speeches
does mattow think her viewers are
children who can't think for themselves
that's no way for the press to treat the
voters